do you remember do you remember when I
was talking to you about um like the
whole metaphor behind logs and indices
and how it's really thinking in terms of
time rather than think in terms of
growth that's kind of the difference
between raising something to a power
versus thinking of its equivalent long
okay now just to add one other sort of
grounding underneath this for why logs
are so worth it like why take a question
which you can do many of these questions
purely with indices
why bother thinking about it in a
logarithmic way and at least one of the
answers is because well there was a
study done actually several studies done
a long time ago about like children
right and where the children are born
with a sense of number or not right like
1 2 3 4 5 etc is that like a natural
inborn thing like is that you know all
human beings everywhere are going to
have numbers or is that something which
we apply from the outside and it's kind
of this this foreign idea now I wonder
what you think the answer would be
hahaha I was I wasn't going to say that
but since you mentioned it actually is
exactly that question like is much
invented by humans and therefore it's
completely foreign right or is it
something which is you know common to
all of us it's part of the fabric every
we up now interestingly enough the
answer is to the question is number
innate in humans or not the answer is
yes yes is yes but not these numbers um
we think of these as like these are
these are numbers right when I say to
you okay
think of numbers this is what the tops
to your mind this is invented okay
the technical term for this which you've
probably just thinking of these numbers
this is arithmetic okay this is numbers
going plus 1 plus 1 plus 1 etc right
another way of thinking about it is it's
a linear way of looking at numbers
because the numbers grow at a steady
rate really interesting experiments done
there went into my Akita jungles places
where people don't have formal education
like oh yeah I did your 11 maths I could
think places where that doesn't exist
okay and they said okay what's halfway
between 1 and 10 well it's now just not
worrying about like precise averages and
my kind of thing most Western people
would say 5 is halfway
don't don't 5 and 1/2 minute don't worry
you get the point right then 5
arithmetic li is ish halfway between 4
and 10 but in these villages right
places where they understood numbers all
I can think they just didn't have a
formal system when asked what was
halfway between one and ten minutes f5
universally they said three now why why
would it be three okay and it doesn't
take that much effort to think about
like if you see a group of people case
you're see group of people there's like
100 people in the crowd okay and you
like add one more person that group
looks pretty much the same it looks
pretty much the same hundred people 101
people so there's like intuitively to
like say a little child right the
difference between to say that the
difference between 1 and 2 is the same
as the difference between a hundred and
a hundred and one that doesn't make
sense
because two is twice the size of one
you've doubled the group whereas you've
hardly managed change you wouldn't even
notice you looked away then turn back
and there's one more person there you'd
say it's the same size right so the
reason why 3 3 is halfway between 1 and
10 is because well 3 is three times
bigger than if there were one thing
there right and if you wanted to get to
10 well that's roughly another three
times bigger okay so this is a this is a
logarithmic scale right in the same way
like all of our senses work in exactly
the same way right if you put your hand
in like real temperature water at room
temperature so it's like 25 degrees okay
and you increase the temperature to like
you know 26 degrees you would feel no
change no change right
but in order for you to feel like oh
this is you know if I fight boozed it
sounds like fifty degrees
now that difference you can feel because
it's double right
it's a the distances between things
right as you you know the difference in
25 to 26 right versus versus like 50 to
51 right these kind of differences here
are thinking oh yes that's the same
difference it's not the same difference
right so words are actually your inbuilt
number system right and we beat it out
of you thoroughly because as soon as you
can
like in before you can talk as soon as
you can make sounds we say why and
Sesame Street gets in on there TQ song
so like what did before but I still have
it in my head right the song for 1 to 12
back from when L is whatever 3 of weasal
so all of that to say vlogs actually
there's a real argument to say logs are
the real numbers right there the actual
numbers that we all think in terms of
and this is a construct on the outside
no wonder so many people have trouble
with it so we're putting these levels of
distraction on how do you even start to
work with this then you have a lot of
laws at your disposal that you can use
pin to manipulate it in terms of these
pieces right ok so there's an easy one
that jumps out of you what's the first
most immediate thing you can see ok good
75 is a multiple of three it's not even
which in the second will cause us some
problems but that's okay we'll rewrite
this as log base 10 of 3 by 25 okay so
so far so good now with your log Wars
because this is a product here but this
is really mean about the log yeah good
this is actually two different logs that
have been added together that's what
produces the product so I've got log
base 10 of 3 plus this okay so
immediately I've gotten rid of this
that's good I've made the problem
simpler okay this guy over here though
looks a bit awkward
not not impossible to work with someone
give me a suggestion what can we do with
this thing
yeah okay let's go step back before that
right this thing here 25 is 5 squared
right so it's really important because
it's all about showing you all your crap
from here I can use my power I can bring
that out the front okay so that's gonna
be one a plus 2 log 10 5 and this point
some of you hit a brick wall because
you're like why what do I do here this
is not a product of anything useful 1 &
5 its prime right um so I can't do I
can't do this decomposition trick what
can I really do with this thing now you
still need to keep making in terms of
products and division yeah very good so
this this step is really hard to see
because do you remember when we're
talking about trig functions sorry trig
identities and sometimes you have to
make things harder before they become
easier right so you have to turn 5 which
is simplified into something more
complicated which I want to clear you
can then work real right so the key the
key is to say or I have to work in tens
is no other direction I can go in it's
like if you went down to the bottom
you've got sines and cosines you're like
I'm done I can't I can't do any more
identities to make it simpler I have to
climb back up to try and get somewhere
this thing I can apply the same trig bit
in Reverse I've got you can probably see
the pieces now this over here which is
log 10 10 minus log base 10 of 2 which
is one of the pieces I have okay so how
long is it take ten to go into 10 enter
one time period
and this I already have defined as X I'm
pretty much done right I suppose you
could expand + 2 minus 2x and that's all
you need to okay so you can see just
like I did right that here is the
critical step here's the hard part the
rest kind of goes on autopilot right but
that's what you need to train yourself
to see what else can I use here and the
extras you can use this it's just not
immediately obvious you're like 2720 I'm
going to make it in threes your home
um you'll know right so because in
exactly the same way that with indices
when you multiply them it becomes
addition right you must work in terms of
products and factors it's the only way
you can work with logs in order to then
break it apart into different pieces so
that's why yeah you know making that 6
minus 1 or 27 minus whatever is never
going to get you very far
yeah oh yeah yes sure like if you if you
can if you look at that you're like a
hot 300 or 4 that's what I think go
first
be my guest
I know seriously if you do if you do see
it and like after you know now that you
know this trick of you know doing this
maybe it will come quicker to you next
time but it sure isn't like I I'm not
that kind of student so their income is
obvious to me but go for it commission
knowing what